there is a disturbing tick tock
though as most of them are pretty
disturbing going around
uh it shows us the consequences of the
sexual revolution
where a young woman and her two
boyfriends i guess one's a husband and
then also her girlfriend discussed the
dynamics of their sexual polycule
hi my name is anna i am dating everybody
in the polycule i am married to jake
we've been together for eight years and
married for three i'm dating spencer and
we've been together for three and a half
and i am dating ellie and we've been
together just over a month now i am
bisexual and my pronouns are she her
i'm also in charge of this account and
in general
hi i'm jake i'm mary dana and she's
currently my only partner
i am demiromantic which means i only get
feelings for people like romantic
feelings for people if i've been around
them for a while and get to know them
really well and i'm technically
pansexual but i like the bi colors more
so i call myself bisexual
my pronouns are he
they
hi i'm ellie i'm dating anna i'm not
currently dating anybody else um i'm
some flavor of fear
and my pronouns are she her
i'm spencer i'm only dating anna um
i'm bi but like bye
so that this video goes we can cut it
there this video goes on spencer then is
asked what his gender is and he gets
confused and then he sees says gosh i
don't know and he's having and he looks
really lost i think we need to rescue
spencer the one i think we need to send
in a search and rescue team to go help
spencer
really all of these people are hedonists
and deeply disturbed people and
quite degenerate and they need to
be reformed and
improve their lives but spencer
especially seems very lost
the sexual revolution
has been an unmitigated disaster for the
human race
how can a society
go on
with that
it where that is the understanding
of
life
love
sex reproduction or the lack thereof how
can a civilization go on in that
unserious away where the men
are
wearing cat ears and proudly boasting of
how cuckolded they are
and the women are
i don't know they've all got these sort
of glazed out creepy eyes
that everyone's marveling at at this
kind of sex and gender craziness as
though it's new oh it's so new we're in
a brave new world
but it's not new it's this is just
paganism this is just this is what
things were like before christianity
okay
and it wasn't great there's nothing new
under the sun folks
what is rare is not this breaking of all
the rules and all of the taboos and all
of the moral norms that we've had for
the past 50 years what's new is
civilization
and we are throwing it away
for a polycule with creepy anna and her
cat-cuckled husband and her girlfriend
that she's known for a month and poor
spencer who doesn't know what gender he
is right now it can feel like everyone
is getting less less social interaction
less sunlight less steps less time being
in the office and while that last one
might not be so bad don't you want more
well since 1998 priceline has been the
best way for travelers to book the trip
they want at the price they can afford
priceline saves consumers more than one
billion dollars every year so that their
customers never have to miss the moments
that matter with priceline you can save
up to 60 percent on your favorite hotels
and you can also get exclusive deals on
rental cars and flights when you save
more you can do more more walks on the
beach
more talking to strangers more fun
in the sun and no matter where you
travel
still less being in the office which is
always enjoyable there are few things
that feel as good as knowing that you
saved money with the discounts priceline
offers you get that feeling a lot
because you can save more
and you can enjoy more and you can do
more
at priceline every trip is a big deal so
when you're ready to book your next one
you go to priceline.com for the best
deals that will help you get more out of
it
you gotta ring the bell subscribe that
way you'll get notifications if for
whatever reason you do not get
notifications for our videos head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you